from Anthony
Edwards I really think Carl Anthony
towns you know really kind of took the
range in this game you know he was
determined he's had some big games here
in this building before you see the
moment between him and pop and was did a
great job filling in too A A just you
know when he needed to have big moments
ant was big and you know Marne talked
about this during the timeout when Chris
Finch was challenging his team to beat
adults and win this basketball game did
that photo op here between the French
[Music]
Connection what a game interesting game
fascinating game and and for the most
part Minnesota really competed it was
fun Michael it really was double double
for goar it wouldn't been theama 29
Points nine rebounds four assists for
the 19yearold